100000 leuchtenden lämpchen und ein 360
großer weihnachtsmann verwandeln diesen
ort zu einem kleinen weihnachtsparadies
in weihnachtswunderland in marseille
tübing sollen sich die besucher
eigentlich auf das weihnachtsfest
einstimmen können
doch nun hat das ordnungsamt am eingang
ein zaun aufgestellt
leider kein zutritt möglich corona
probiert uns dass das heißt wer zu uns
kommen möchte wird über facebook
anmelden dann gibt es termine und
zeitlos in dem corona konforme neben
einzel führung möglich sind maximal fünf
personen dürfen gleichzeitig über die
2000 quadratmeter laufen aber trotz der
korona maßnahme mit der begrenzten
besucherzahl lassen sich boris und jenny
die weihnachtsstimmung nicht nehmen das
haus und den garten haben sie mit viel
liebe dekoriert und geschmückt bis alles
so aussah
doch eigentlich fing alles ganz klein an
alles begann den reden hier und unsere
liebe zu weihnachten und aus einem
rentieren würden halt immer zwei es
wurden fünf wurden 10
und irgendwann haben wir dann mal
aufgerüstet vor fünf jahren für haben
wir vollgas geben wollte es die
schnelllebige zeit und in der
weihnachtszeit kann man ein bisschen
abschalten runterkommen und da wollen
wir einfach den menschen was schönes
bieten also ein tolles erlebnis und
jetzt in diesem jahr noch umso mehr
und das sieht man auch leuchtende
figürchen die oft tore schießen kleine
schneemänner jubeln ihm zu
und genau neben einem großen stern liegt
das kleine jesuskind in einer krippe die
macht der nation keine probleme
der weihnachtsmann ist mit seinem
schlitten im garten gelandet und macht
eine kleine pause zu weihnachten
schaffen es die geschenke also
wahrscheinlich trotz corona und
aufgestelltem zaun unter die
weihnachtsbäume trotz corona in mücheln
in sachsen anhalt hat jetzt ein kleiner
weihnachtsmarkt eröffnet als drive in
variante am eingang bekommt jeder einen
zettel mit den angebotenen fünf boden
aussteigen soll niemand trotzdem sollen
alle masken tragen
alles was es hier zu kaufen gibt muss
mit nach hause genommen werden oder man
sucht sich einen parkplatz in der nähe
fahrräder und fußgänger sind nicht
erlaubt geöffnet ist immer freitags
samstags und sonntags ab 16 uhr
[Musik]
auch in anderen teilen deutschlands sind
bereits 34 weihnachtsmärkte entstanden
zum beispiel hier in der nähe von
münchen
so kommt trotz corona doch noch etwas
weihnachtsstimmung auf
[Musik]
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
weil bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergessen nicht zu
abonnieren